all right raider nation is pretty fired
up they ought to be reaching the halfway
point of the season and playing
the most difficult part of their
schedule it's over the raiders are five
and three on the season
really should be pretty good right the
latest feel good moment coming sunday
afternoon
when it appeared as if the raiders had
just lost on a last-second touchdown
pass
but after waiting and looking at
monitors the raiders got the word
the receiver did not maintain control of
the ball throughout the process
it's incomplete ah game over look at the
celebration isaiah johnson feeling
crustful and then celebrating just like
that
chargers have lost three of four games
probably they should have won
but sunday's win by the raiders
certainly a testament to this team's
character
you know adversity sometimes is a
perception
you know there's a lot of perception out
there and the reality is here is we we
really like each other
and we respect the job that we've done
against covid we have fun coming to work
we have fun
competing together it's a tight group of
players and coaches and
it's a great environment i wish you guys
could see it but
we have a lot of confidence in the next
man up we've got a good young team